[Music]
hi I'm Colin McNeill for the story
sports you know it seems like just
yesterday we were thinking about what
the overwatch League could be how would
it work who would be the top teams would
it even be a success but here we are
with owi else tej one done and dusted
and the London Spitfire as our champions
so with that in mind let's take a look
back at our favorite plays from pines
unreal pulse bomb sticks their Valkyrie
just saw the few strands and it's gonna
be a whole two shadow burns disgusting
dragon blades and of course pocos
devastating to the ball here is the best
of Oh w-well stage one the tire the tire
put the fear of God in them and they had
to use the Valkyrie Early's ever'one are
you kidding me nation as you're about to
see with the m4 sight and nailed the
shots not many widow-makers would go for
this play that was the fight that we
needed to win and that's managed somehow
someway lives at the pit I was gonna say
fell to the pin euro car paint gets the
couch to Saipan the baby made a freeze
my bow the deck goes down carpe totally
going wild on this Widowmaker right now
oh do you look like it looked like San
Francisco it's such a good opportunity
but Hart Bay is just going to get all
the help that one uses comp and wait for
the players
and dealing this doesn't pose for
nothing left of Dallas fuel but cinders
and charred extremities appointment if
zippers gonna go that deep and get
shoved off and into the midst of the
enemy team and then he can follow us
with a kill like that let a have reset
his Ole Miss all the boss pulse bombs
you do not take and most racers just
throw it out there but try and extract
value out of it extracts the life on a
Dreamcast bird this could be big though
he could actually drop down calyx caught
out in the open bit of a dicey spot for
him and bird ring oh go for the quick
plane styling galaxy's God definitely
did not see that coming and neither did
we
[Music]
Pyne anymore you don't want to keep
running it'll be treating cancer on the
flank here I don't know man I have been
impressed I I think London's done a
great job of zoning out that Kim G -
it's perfect for Pfizer pistol Wow yeah
Florida mayhem should be able to get
some decent movement on the payload
right here transcendence use life by
Kareem and not gonna be helping out Oh
meatball tipic he has killed Agility's
three times and why me we're gonna get
some of the replays here and really you
can't be disappointed with Lakers
performance man just seems to stand out
on every front pick after pick they're
playing in the sandbox so excited and
then it just falls apart in his hands
immediately it's not been a great
bastion day for sleepy that's control so
he's gonna get off and onto a four cup
for your baby baby while hitting head
shot after head shot London stalling out
the attack Cisco shocked but goes in
huge plays always on that Zegna well
when you're running this composition
with the double sniper it kind of greens
because you're running only one support
and rest of them
anymore single support seen under
supplies like mono and make her the good
Lord hates me gonna have to wait -
that's a cute trick fire
happy birthday New York
so they'll lose their mercy days he fled
a boat take out the Vicky knew he was
roaming around in that courtyard mutter
with another make it three play around
here here go into the antenna gravity
it's by part of the map usually you
don't see too much action over here but
why not let anyone on peace and quiet
and pink for a moment ok drop on the
points let's beat the EMP though is
probably ball looking for show then this
could be nasty news was so close to the
found Creek to keep her this is a fight
they should win and that's a great start
for men as well man it's an out of the
mix
[Applause]
tae Moo finding crucial pick right when
Dallas needs it now but they're not done
yet though they've nearly got it through
the point beat
KOCO does fall though the hero play but
can't they reenact okay but is their
presence on the card over time says
there he's got to use it
she'll bring 7pz dragon played here we
go comes in five kilo that's what
[Applause]
Houston needs when they have a grab that
should be able to get it done he's come
up with a good smile on that face
layoffs pinkies [ __ ] up mistake
because of the other players allergic
slowly minutes and kept him alive with a
bit of defense matrix forward that with
the resurrection yeah they had to wait
for the barrier that's why it took so
long for arc and now they are going to
charge forward into the Spitfire oh man
sho'nac by the hook finding the kills
but another one comes in he's got an odd
cooldown he's got no option he's got a
safe way to get out that's why Pete I'm
pretty appease they get him out to be
the first to fall this shields not
stripped away and so is this hell
Neptune no second rocks is open this
bottom like a nice little oyster and now
they're enjoying the sweet insides the
point belongs to the outlaws Manik does
go down a res comes in from NY Excel and
here comes fine gets one gets two
looking for a bit more
are you kidding me this guy is gonna
single-handedly change the point back
over oh okay
hi Big Boss line is on the scene has
gone to right now there's tick number to
run to trying to get in they do get baby
baby MV use of sleepy balls and now
hearing in EMP he's gonna be able to use
that whole hog will it be tan up though
with that Mel Korean maybe oh how did he
get that bug man just fishing rule the
roost now the trade setup comes in a lot
to hold in these situations and they're
not communicating about Reds time
Explorer very effectively there's one
try to find that midair shot on our key
gets it with the second one
make sure that he stays alive but this
teammate somehow the London Spitfire
have dive bugs back onto the site though
they've succeeded in just stalling it
out a little bit longer but dream Casper
headed rocket rocket then we go three
big frags Bertram Casper and that will
finally take it over in Boston's favor
New York Excel you have to give it to
have a keep fighting back not give it up
profit what is inside go the brim tire
it is
blank different angle here and it will
be fine our carcass ball durable
and that might be the turning point here
that might be what London Smith bar
we're waiting for sip Dobby is close
enough to contest that the last possible
instant but he's not gonna be around for
long
Eagles drum crab right now is in the sky
baby Bebo encounters seagulls junk crab
right now is in the sky and baby babe
removes him from the equation fairly
early on here and in fact he is still in
this fight getting healed up as well you
can see chips and very early maybe
things he'd get me MP with just damaged
blade comes in from baby baked maybe
could have got more of a guest to they
are speaking so much progress on this
second point Madison the pulse bomb
ready to go just needs to get a good
sick man Oh balls that's a good search
Oh
he got stuck down to the chance here oh
the kills are coming in now good
sephora's this one dressed kids can pop
Alka Ken old patches can have another
resume well if he wants it but I think
this damage is too much shadow burn
we'll put the finishing blows on it
justice reigns from above pulping on the
transcendent down till they see has a
bumper but he wants five key it wasn't
something resurrect he's gonna know drag
it might find this box beginning to list
down the bills that note tolling his
free fell also gets going brown white
one the bro drops back even now the
dragon place was simply doing until we
found to you the transcendence for a
shadow burn with the dragon blade see
here their instant replay the
self-destruction 1000 J run to the
corner there ran for the hills that
could quite get to the bunker in time
the points and their striker who is
certainly been performing second life
you're still gonna get blown to bits
boston uprising right now striker is
just styling
although knows at that point there's no
more resurrects available for
Reinhardt's yes dragonblade time there
goes altering a kill for Seagal of the
swoops in with the graviton surge Dante
nearly there with one of his own there
we go at cc time Frankie just catch a
ball
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
connected for the rest of the outlaws
though they need to go anyway I'm
assuming the primer right here a lot
more HP printer without nothing but a
gross looking mirror on the roof of an
uber city's fatty and another one can
see now starting to really wake up
looking reception put the James you from
the owl try to find the angle on the man
who's made his life absolutely miserable
in affection a later transcendence is
going to be a better transcended there
we go buddy there we go yeah a lot of
resources Bigfoot supposed to become
logics of course my transverse it's not
gonna be its to look to Rockets it just
doesn't get any better than that now let
me try to avoid the Baraka parents
coming down alright agility is with that
ripped I are gonna try to stop this bush
before it starts down on high there's
two robots great liabilities the worst
possible circumstance out of New York
only a couple percent away can they hold
it Houston needs to make this fight
happen right now they need to grind it
out and they're getting the kill Sidhu
just fat high in a little bit on his own
here all but he takes plaque work out as
he comes in totaling sir here's the
heart Kari gets Betty
there's another one flying that this guy
is unstoppable
the portals on either side right now
it's gonna be Frankie leaving on in I
did indeed try to pick people off in the
air Vishu a late hold on the
self-destruct looking everybody up
playing boundary conditions
falling down we tell about it's so easy
to scratch damage across again the two
of them is the book but they only have
xqc there now a it matters to his
feelings
Oh oops for the boob God look
line the bottom of the well no fur on
here
is that a nice job really landing these
shots on in shape forcing it back a
little bit he's also forcing the Moses
that close to Jake that's the one-two
punch we were looking for and now I
might beat struggle city for raucous
he's trying to hide back around the
corner matte shadow man's got the
verticality wants the mercy you better
believe I'll have it as well extra
rockets surplus damage that's all should
have been need three kills with apparent
for under what clockwork now we have
ourselves a game and the fusion what do
you say about links is already over the
edge moon life jackets the Batman
frustration absorber go back to the SEC
turn a list a little overtime pyramid
ropes down bubble drop team this Cordova
tank he might be over the end as well
now nor again continue to be strong
right over time now Los Angeles ring
control the point Last Chance elderly
for Shanghai to bring us back back in
free Phil is turning to expensive
cutlery the optic bunkers no more
traction makes it three beautiful staff
from the gladiators and once again it's
a map that goes for the purple in once
sir is out matt is usually
johnny-on-the-spot trying to make her
ass that high ground up there really no
kills from a huge swing back and forth
out both be very careful make sure it
gets another kill in that fight the
murder
battle bird see what is going on your
father did you expect to see him at this
level today crumbs I did actually I did
expect to see him go pop off because the
only times we see shadow Byrne struggle
is mostly when the team focus is so hard
to shut him down but it wasn't even just
him cuz we get the seen them to know
here just pop off on battle mercy rotate
and give that up but they'll take the
trade with baby Bay as well will drop
know me point-blank its forced overtime
the rest of Philadelphia needs to get
those those easy to get there in a hurry
soon cousin grandpa pop sorrow and uses
it
everybody dead by the time the
self-destruct goes off didn t even need
it
Oh t take it away and L a valiant will
take Oasis - OH
20 seconds of defense away from being
the stage 1 champions one last fight to
decide our victor here we go here comes
a rip tire profit a pick here could be
$100,000 ultimate goodie - it oh he's
out to the first he gets arc that's huge
transcendence comes in from Kodak
New York scrambling that is it liberal
Last Man Standing
Oh deep ticking away and that is in
London Spitfire will be your overwatch
League stage 1 champions
[Music]
in their 14th game of the day the
roofers sweep from London coming back to
take home $100,000 thanks for watching
if you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button